gli ecosistemi hanno un intelligenza
acustica per tentare di capirlo sto
conducendo un progetto di ricerca a
lungo termine che indaga l'elemento più
rilevante che in una foresta densa
giunge ai nostri sensi
il suono
ho sempre avuto una specie di ossessione
nel raccogliere i suoni dell'ambiente
sin da quando da giovanissimo nelle
nelle campagne e nei boschi di urbino
dove sono nato e passavo letteralmente
nottate intere a registrare aspettare
registrare il paesaggio sonoro perfetto
l'idea era quella di dare la possibilità
ad altri di fare la stessa esperienza di
meraviglia nell'ascolto dell'ambiente
acustico oggi sono un compositore sound
designer il segno musica elettroacustica
e studio il mondo sonoro naturale da
circa 15 anni da quando ho fatto
un'esperienza nel febbraio 2002 in
amazzonia in un'area della nazionale
centrale che confermava gran parte delle
delle intuizioni fino a quel momento
durante la registrazione di un desk
korjus il coro del crepuscolo quel
graduale momento di passaggio che sarà
tra il giorno e la notte che è
generalmente molto attivo negli habitat
naturali
ho capito che quell ordine ed equilibrio
che percepivo era il risultato tangibile
di tutti i processi dell'ecosistema
istante per istante attraverso i
microfoni molto sensibili con cui stavo
registrando ho ascoltato per tre ore
consecutive le vocalizzazioni coordinate
e interdipendenti delle varie specie che
eseguiva non ha una precisa partitura
scritta probabilmente dall evoluzione
naturale di dalla selezione naturale a
di 65 milioni di anni di evoluzione le
centinaia di voci di questa polifonia
erano attivate in prima istanza da luce
temperatura umidità in modo automatico
quasi ma ogni individuo emetteva dei
segnali acustici dei segnali sonori con
una precisa e specifica funzione vitale
nulla a caso e questi segnali entravano
in nicchie sonore frequenziali e
temporali
nell'arco delle 24 ore intere percepivo
che quell'orologio era tuttavia un
meccanismo fragilissimo tanto più
fragile quanto più alta era la
biodiversità del sistema e dell'abitato
in cui la canoa stava entrando il tutto
il pianeta
oggi quel miracolo di sincronia bio
acustica e in via di estinzione
[Applauso]
[Musica]
la registrazione precedente a questo
video quello che sentivamo in sottofondo
è stata fatta e la nazionale 2002
se oggi andassimo nello stesso identico
luogo nella stessa stagione nella stessa
ora del giorno e con le stesse
tecnologie la registrazione
probabilmente sarebbe già più povera e
meno organizzata lasciatemi vivere
qualche dato sull'estinzione il tasso di
estinzione presente è stato calcolato
essere tra le 100 e le mille volte
superiore all'estinzione di fondo quella
naturale la you see an international
union for conservation of national
l'organo deputato pubblica dei dati
abbastanza sconvolgenti un ottavo degli
uccelli un quarto dei mammiferi e quasi
la metà degli anfibi delle specie
conosciute e monitorate entrata nella
lista rossa delle specie in estinzione
le previsioni degli anni 90 che
parlavano di 30.000 di un'ipotesi di
30.000 specie l'anno ovvero quattro
specie ogni ora grano estinte si sono
rivelate corrette e in atto una
catastrofe silenziosa assolutamente non
trattata dai media la vita sta
globalmente collassando
in quella che viene definita la sesta
estinzione di massa che questa volta è
provocata dall'impatto cosciente direi
di una specie homo sapiens sulla
biosfera
la forestazione inquinamento e specie
invasive come drivers diciamo
dell'estinzione
ma soprattutto i cambiamenti climatici
che oggi si aggiungono stanno
modificando gli habitat naturali e li
stanno impoverendo ad un livello molto
ampio e velocizzato la situazione è
talmente grave che non non c'è tempo di
dimostrare anche con il suono che le
cose stanno cambiando
come spesso mi viene chiesto ma stai
comparando le registrazioni tra tra il
passato e il presente non sento questa
esigenza bensì un esigenza diversa
quella di registrare il prima possibile
in più luoghi possibili frammenti di
questo patrimonio sonoro in materiale
il progetto fragmento extension già
scritto nel 1998 sta registrando quindi
interi cicli circadiani di 24 ore di
registrazione continua in habitat molto
specifici quelli che hanno la più alta
biodiversità come priorità
l'area di interesse è quella intorno
all'equatore 5 gradi sud 5 gradi nord
sappiamo che all'equatore l'incidenza
delle stagioni è minima e la durata di
giorno e notte e uniforme da milioni di
anni
quindi i ritmi del paesaggio sonoro sono
estremamente regolari molto belli
all'interno di quest'area
la priorità va nelle foreste perché sono
primarie ovvero sono il loro stato
originario intatte e all'interno di
queste aree
la priorità va in foreste che sono
indisturbate ad oggi quindi non c'è
nessun tipo di attività umana luoghi
remoti in questi ecosistemi remoti
possiamo davvero ancora rintracciare la
firma acustica dell'evoluzione ma
appunto bisogna fare in fretta per
fissare a beneficio delle generazioni
future
l'impronta acustica di polyphony e
primordiali che si degraderanno
velocemente il progetto fragments of
extension è sempre stato è stato nutrito
diciamo dal dall'essere al crocevia tra
varie discipline di ricerca e approcci
quello tecnologico sulla registrazione
3d del suono quindi le tecnologie più
avanzate oggi disponibili
quello della scienza l'analisi ecologica
del cus tico dei dati l'arte quindi la
creazione la realizzazione di sistemi
per la fruizione museale sistemi
immersivi per l'ascolto museale e di
documentari sonori tridimensionali e
l'impegno ambientalistico ovviamente
quello che permette di comunicare quello
che sta accadendo attraverso un progetto
interdisciplinare dunque questo progetto
si confronta ovviamente con molte
difficoltà dal portare tutte queste
tecnologie che vedete nell'ultimo
viaggio abbiamo fatto registrazioni di
24 ore con 38 canali aperti quindi 38
tracce 38 microfoni che vengono
registrati contemporaneamente per dirvi
la mole dei dati un terabyte e mezzo di
dati portati a casa in tre settimane
sostanzialmente e la difficoltà di far
funzionare tutte queste tecnologie a
batterie nei luoghi che dove l'energia
elettrica si raggiunge
raramente e di doverle montare e
installare in luoghi ovviamente non
canonici perché andiamo spesso in alto
per vari motivi
fino a quelle della vita quotidiana
ovviamente prima di tutte di tutti
l'umidità che arriva spesso al 95 sulla
soglia vicino al 100 per cento e grande
nemico delle tecnologie in questo caso
vedete questa è una foto del 2008
eravamo in repubblica centrafricana
qui il sistema è stato messo in modo
automatico perché non si poteva stare in
foresta durante la notte per il pericolo
dell'attacco di elefanti che oggi
vengono cacciati come sappiamo e quindi
attaccano l'uomo
ascoltiamo un piccolo frammento con due
specie di scimmie e una di elefanti lo
spettro del suono grave
voglio raccontarvi un ultimo episodio ci
trovavamo in amazzonia
questa foto che vediamo nel febbraio
eravamo a diverse ore di canoa e poi di
cammino per raggiungere un area molto
specifica della foresta primaria
indisturbata e ho deciso di rimanere
solo quella notte a a controllare le
attrezzature proprio per impattare il
meno possibile in questo habitat di
questa registrazione di 24 ore che
dovevamo fare bene quando arrivata la
notte buio quasi assoluto nel letto
della foresta
ho avuto paura ho avuto davvero paura
dopo ora e diciamo di lotta con me
stesso per riuscire a uscire fuori da
questa impellenza di andarmene in un
ambiente
ovviamente quasi completamente
sconosciuto alla scienza è in cui mi
sentivo un estraneo
e stato proprio l'ascolto a
riconnettermi a calmarmi diciamo ho
ascoltato come non avevo mai ascoltato
prima o ho sentito il flusso degli
eventi o ho ascoltato il principio che
teneva insieme le parti di questo
sistema straordinario che stava vivendo
intorno a me ed è stato proprio appunto
l'ascolto profondo a farmi in qualche
modo riconnettere ea farmi passare la
paura
ascoltiamo un piccolo estratto di questa
registrazione
[Musica]
sì
qui
[Musica]
ma chi
sì
[Musica]
negli anni da compositore che creava la
musica sono diventato colui che la cerca
in natura che la conserva e che
eventualmente la ripropone non è stato
facile rinunciare alla creatività
propria di quello che fa un musicista ma
ho progettato in questi anni degli spazi
immersivi per la fruizione dove è
possibile ascoltare in per i fonia
sferica quindi con una definizione mai
tentata ascoltare questi paesaggi sonori
primordiali come fossimo in una macchina
del tempo ho una strana sala da concerto
o in un tempio se preferiamo e se
estendiamo ora questi questa visione
alla generazione i nostri nipoti oppure
dei loro figli
le registrazioni di cui stiamo parlando
saranno l'unico modo di fare esperienza
di quanto straordinaria e complessa
era la bio fonia del mondo naturale di
voi lasciare con una domanda che mi
faccio spesso è questi questi luoghi
questi spazi questi teatri eco acustici
potrebbero davvero diventare un mezzo
per la riconnessione al mondo naturale
al servizio del cambio di paradigma che
l'umanità dovrà fare obbligatoriamente
nei prossimi decenni
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]